producers Cash Cash are back with new
music returning to Sin City last night
at zuke nightclub yes our executive
producer Saloon Selena to asan chatted
with one of the group's members about
their road to success something that
took more than blood sweat in three
years
they've been making music for almost two
decades and are behind some of the
biggest songs to hit the airwaves
what about all the plans
[Music]
since 2008 the Platinum pop electronic
music group Cash Cash have played more
than a thousand shows the trio made up
of John Paul Alex and Sam are known for
their skills not just on the turntables
but also for their songwriting and some
artists they just do music and tracks
all that stuff we're more focused on
songwriting and
um vocals and making pop music that will
you know that could be timeless and
lasts forever it sometimes it only takes
one phrase of a small combination of
words that can make the hair stand up on
the back of your neck or give you
Goosebumps
lyrics that can be heard with their
latest single anyway featuring Ruth Ann
the first EP out in almost two years
that's simple concept of like loving
somebody for their flaws loving them no
matter what no matter what goes down
it's like no we're in this like this is
forever but it's the lyric and title of
their highest charting song to date take
me home with Bebe rexa that brings back
JP to the group's humble beginnings we
ended up like having to move back home
so we did all that stuff my parents
basement literally my mom would be like
bringing us coffee and like Scotty's
down in between takes I remember I
pulled my car into the driveway on the
side of my my parents house and it was
on the radio looking through the
windshield I could see the basements
studio and it was just like I had a
moment where I was just like how did I
get the music from here on the radio
from that room to here on the radio
[Music]
Five albums numerous EPs and official
remixes with artists like Kelly Clarkson
Katy Perry and Bruno Mars Cash Cash
continues to cash in on their success
which shows all over the world including
an ongoing residency at Zoot nightclub
there's no other club there's nothing
quite like it like they built it from
the from scratch and they they talk to
all the DJs to find out what DJ's like
what DJs want what do you want in a
nightclub when the article do it has a
better Vibe the the club goers and the
people are going to get a better
experience it's second to none and the
trio shows no signs of surrender
[Music]
we've been so lucky to just constantly
be checking you know
check marks off on that bucket list to
this day to have 30 000 people singing
the song that we made in that basement
you know like it's the little thing when
you put it in perspective
you're grateful you know and
it's crazy
[Music]
that is good stuff anyway is out now and
the trio returns to Vegas in March
comedy and rock and roll